Speaker 1: All right. Let's go next to Sarah.
Sarah Bera, I guess I'm not exactly sure. Sara.
Speaker 2: Hi. How are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 2: Okay. So I have a question regarding
information and debating, like I said,
probation. So for example, when we're debating
against conservatives, right, about, let's say
Donald Trump's 17 you indictments or his possible
fate when it comes to Jan six, how do you deal
with people who just say, oh, no, no, that's all
right. That's that's that's all your information
is a lie. All your sources are not true, but my
sources are true. How do you defend against that?
Speaker 1: If they are really in such bad faith
saying all your sources aren't accurate and all of
mine are, that's really, really extreme. And so I
don't even know that I would mess with that. Now,
I think oftentimes it's not quite so it's
extreme. It's I don't really believe that
they're you'd say, well, why not? Well, I
don't trust the source. Okay. What sources
do you trust? How do you determine what sources
are trustworthy? What evidence from which source
could I present you that would change your mind
about whether this particular thing is or isn't
true? You have to start with the Socratic method
of questioning to try to establish how they even
determine what they can believe in general. But
when someone just if it's really as bad as every
source you're looking at, it can't be trusted. You
got to look only at my sources. I would honestly
not even waste my time with people that extreme.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I'll say I agree with that,
especially when they're acting in such bad
faith that it's almost impossible. Yes. Like
a good like an actual conversation without
them. Just like setting aside every single
source that you have 100%.
Speaker 1: And by the way,
we have a guide that's free for how to manage
a lot of these conversations with people. The
guide is at David Pakman dot com slash guide.
I'm not selling anybody anything. It's just
because you brought it up. It's like an
eight or ten page paper. It's a guide,
it's free. And it gives you a lot of techniques
actually, for how to talk to these people.
Speaker 2: Oh, that's cool. I'll
definitely be looking into that. Yeah.
Thank you so much for answering my question.
Speaker 1: My absolute pleasure. Thank you so
much for the call. That will do it for today.
But the new system on discord has been an
unmitigated success, ladies and gentlemen. So
thank you to everybody who helped set it up,
in particular the moderators.
And we will take calls again
and we will use a system like this
one next week. Thank you very much.